just a quick warning I had to re-upload
this video because apparently YouTube
considers this word on the same level as
the f word and you can't say that within
the first seven seconds of the video so
without further Ado here we go wash your
Ducks the apocalypse is right around the
corner with black mirror's final episode
of Season Six Demon 79 explores what
would happen if you were haunted by the
lead singer of Boney M and in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into its
ending a ton of Black Mirror Easter eggs
and making sure to eat my lunch in a
creepy basement so come along with me
and like And subscribe because my demon
Susan wijicki says that if I don't get
at least 10 subscribers this video will
end oh she's not the president anymore
well I guess there's nothing more
British than living on top of a fish and
chip shop that's where we'll find our
protagonists need a Huck as art
Garfunkel's song Bright Eyes plays this
was a song originally written as the
theme for the animated movie Watership
Down and the bright eyes refer to the
rabbit's wide-eyed expression as it
navigates a world filled with peril just
like our protagonist the episode looks
like it was filmed on super 16 which
would be common back in 1979 when the
story takes place Anita works in the
Footwear Department of possets where she
has to endure her racist co-worker Vicky
and customers like Keith Hollinger who
gets a bit intimate with the Footwear
and it's here Nida experiences the first
of her hallucinations bashing Vicky's
head into the counter and strangling
Keith just a typical day of work it's
pretty ironic then that we find her
reading a book called creative
visualization which is all about using
mental imagery to produce positive
changes in one's life if it can produce
positive ones can it also produce
negative but to really understand Nita's
Story one must understand the political
backdrop of 1979 Britain Rising
unemployment High inflation and
Industrial strikes made for a volatile
situation and some like the national
front party used immigrants as a
scapegoat for the country's problems
we'll see Vicky reading a national front
flyer which says stop immigration
protect British culture Anita will have
the letters NF spray painted on her door
by some local outside of posits
we get our first look at Michael smart a
man running is the Conservative
candidate in tipley Smart's name can be
found in a ton of articles in episode
2's to lock Henry and there's even a
documentary about him on streamberry
found in episode ones Joan is awful
we'll get to know a little bit more
about Mr smart and his vision for
Britain in a bit but first the episode's
inciting incident while being asked by
her boss to eat in the basement due to a
complaint by Vicky that her lunch smells
Nita uncovers a desk belonging to
posit's founder Jeffrey posset it said
that in his last days posset hold
himself up here and it seems he became
obsessed with local crimes Nita uncovers
several old articles the first about a
man dying in a fire the second a man
crushed by a wall and the third a
woman's sudden disappearance keep in
mind this number three as it becomes a
recurring mode teeth throughout the
episode now there is a brief mention of
someone called callow in a different
article but unsure if this has any
relation to a future Prime Minister
Michael kallo from season 1's the
national anthem things take a turn when
Nita Nicks her finger and blood drops on
this odd looking Domino a domino which
will later be referred to as a Talisman
it kind of looks like a fork with two
prongs sticking from it a dead ringer
for the white bear logo from season two
for some reason she ends up taking this
Talisman with her and while at home is
greeted to the demon known as GA who
says that the Talisman Anointed with her
blood means they are now linked she must
sacrifice three humans over the next
three days or the world will end but in
order for Gap to help her she has to
agree to it and in an act of fear she
agrees Gap is the name of a demon found
in the dictionary infernal and also a
place where you can get some reasonably
priced clothing he's considered a prince
of hell with the ability to change his
shape and see into the past future in
our story he possesses these abilities
but isn't as high ranking in fact he
says that Nida is part of his initiation
and should she fail to murder three
people he'll be cast out into Oblivion
for all eternity no pressure later in
the episode while calling his superiors
he refers to himself as a missile phase
which according to 10th Century Eastern
Byzantine religion were one of the
lowest class of demons when Nita accepts
gap's help notice what happens to the
Talisman it has three lines instead of
two each line representing a murder she
must commit with a line disappearing
every time she's successful does this
mean then that the last person to
possess this Talisman only killed one
person and does it have anything to do
with the newspaper articles Nida
discovered I have my own Theory which
I'll share in just a bit to ease Nita's
fears Gap takes on a form a little more
appealing than this and transforms into
a singer from German Caribbean vocal
group bony M something Nida had been
watching the previous 9 night he shows
her what will happen should she not kill
three people the world will be plunged
into fire as we'll find out later this
will manifest in a nuclear apocalypse
between the U.S and Russia fearing the
end of the world Nita embarks on her
quest to kill only targeting people who
deserve it her first victim being Tim
Simon Gap can show Nita what these evil
people have done in the hopes of making
her kills more justifiable for example
Nida can see how Tim sexually abuses his
daughter making him a prime candidate to
get whacked in the head with a brick
this becomes Nita's first kill and a
line from her Talisman disappears
alerted to the body is detective Len
Fisher who we first see reading
jean-lucale's spy novel Smiley's people
which came out in 1979 and
coincidentally has Dominoes on the front
he always seems to be one step behind
Nida throughout her Killing Spree now
Nita has to find victim number two
deciding to check out the local pub the
three crowns there's three again after
opting against killing her co-worker
Vicky may be racist but that's not
enough for Nita to kill her she's gonna
need a a bit more here she'll find Keith
Hollinger the absolute creep who hit on
her at work and who's said to have
gotten away with the murder of his wife
something Gap confirms this will be her
next victim
stalking him back home she's caught but
Keith thinks she's into him and invites
her over for some sexy dancing the
interesting thing about Keith is that
when Nita goes to kill him he accepts it
I deserve and thus Keith becomes Anita's
second victim but there's a problem his
flatmate and brother Chris has seen her
if Nita is going to prevent the
apocalypse she'll have to kill the
witness even if he's a completely
innocent man what ensues is a super
awkward hammer and knife fight which
sees Chris stabbed in the chest Nita
should be done her three kills but a
line Still Remains on the Talisman so
Gap calls his superiors using the number
666 no less and finds out Keith's killed
in count because murderers are
ineligible you'd think he'd have learned
that in Demon school sonida has to go
back to work and think about who to kill
next that's when Michael smart comes in
need a ass Gap if he'd be a good
candidate but he knows his superiors
wouldn't be happy if Nida killed him
technically his kill would count towards
the three but as we'll see when he shows
Nita Michael Smart's future this man is
going to bring a lot of pain and hatred
to the country we get a glimpse of this
when Michael asks who Vicki's going to
vote for she wants the far-right
national front party because they'll get
those immigrants out of the country but
Michael tells her she'd just be throwing
her vote away the national front has no
chance of winning why not vote for him
and he basically tells her he's a racist
in disguise
you know why and this is backed up when
Nita is shown Michael's future we see a
sign that smart gets kicked out of the
Tories for racist remarks something that
is also found in an article in lock
Henry he starts a completely new party
called Britannia something he threatened
to do in an article in lockhenry as well
even the Britannia party logo is in the
shape of the white bear in Michael
smarts Britain people of color are
surveilled houses are raided immigrants
struggle there's viruses fires and even
the symbols at his campaign rallies
would make Goebbels blush there's even
the use of those metal dogs from season
4's metalheads something we can see
Michael smart was to unveil in episode
2's lock Henry Len tracks down Nida
after finding out she was also at the
pub the night Keith was murdered he has
written proof that the two had met
before and it kind of makes her a
suspect but at this point he doesn't
have any definitive proof he lets her go
and secretly follows her soon realizing
that Nita is also following Michael I
also found it really cheeky that Michael
smart listens to the tanhauser Overture
by Richard Wagner a known anti-semite
Nina does her best fast and furious
causing Michael's car to crash into a
nearby tree but unfortunately he's still
alive and she has to finish the job and
I gotta say I love this satanic choral
music when she goes in but Len is there
to stop her and Eda is quick to say
sorry but if you listen closely she's
apologizing to Gap because she was
unsuccessful he'll now have to spend
eternity in Oblivion or at least that's
what we think will happen once the clock
strikes 12. while being interrogated the
detectives go over her story which
sounds completely insane and they
revealed that the Talisman has been a
domino the whole time as midnight hits
it looks like nothing has happened but a
short moment later Airaid Sirens go off
and Britain is in the middle of a
full-scale nuclear attack if we're to
believe what follows next happens she
accepts gaps offer to come with her to
Oblivion and humanity is plunged into an
apocalypse but I don't think that's what
happened I think it was is all in her
head at the beginning of the episode
were introduced to Nita's dead mother
who will later find out suffered from
mental troubles Nita even says she went
mad could Nita also have inherited these
traits we know that she experiences
hallucinations such as throwing Vicki
into the counter this happened before
her meeting with gap and it seems as
though elements from her real life
influence her hallucinations for example
the articles in the department store
basement refer to three deaths they
include fire and references to MayDay
the time in which her kills must be
completed unfortunately there's no date
on those articles but it's possible they
could be from 1926 which is the year
gaps of the Talisman was created
additionally we have Gap himself who
takes the form of Boney M who Nita
watched the night before the apocalypse
is likely a hallucination as well we see
Nita talking to the police and then the
camera cuts to the clock but when we cut
back the detectives are completely
outside of the room it's only been a few
seconds there's no way they could have
gotten out there in that amount of time
and not have made a sound it also makes
sense that Nina would hallucinate the
apocalypse as it would help justify her
kills and compartmentalize her trauma I
think the real Nida is locked up
somewhere in her own little world we
also know from Lock Henry that Michael
smart is Alive and Well suggesting the
apocalypse never happened but we also
know these Black Mirror episodes are
just Loosely related to one another but
I want to hear what you think did Nita
end up with gap in Oblivion or is she
spending the rest of her days in a psych
ward I want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone please be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstoryyt until next time remember
[Music]
foreign